comment tu vas toujours alain ferry tu
veux quoi d'arrêt je veux simplement que
tu as she samper fait huit ans qu'elle
t'a pas vu tu as même pas dit au revoir
bonjour eva pourquoi tu es là je veux
envie de te voir
je dois y aller mais sami m'attendent on
m'a dit que cet endroit dans notre fille
a disparu
amelia m'a dit qu'elle l'avait pas vue
depuis hier elle est là ou pas pourquoi
cet avis maintenant elle n'est pas
rentrée à la maison hier soir être
qu'elle vous évite kaunas où je me
levais notre fils est venu si hier avec
des amis mais elle n'est pas rentrée à
la maison
votre fille était dans le coin elle est
partie dans ce cas joyeux pour vous
souvenez de moi et de cet endroit
regardez vous votre état s'aggrave
croyez moi il ne vous reste plus
beaucoup
ce n'est pas ici ils ne comprendront pas
est ce que vous l'avez vu vous c'est
quoi
je suis pour rien
est ce que vous savez sur la disparition
de jeunes filles dans le coin
attendez je m'en fiche si relais de quoi
tu parles
elle est bonne
vous
[Musique]
dois-je venir en personne pop jusqu'à
chez toi pour la récupérer toute
approche de ma famille
je vais d'abord son sens car ou est ce
qu'elle est
et ma fille